[Music]
foreign
what can I do for you okay picture a
cell phone and an email machine all in
one thing
there is a free wireless internet signal
all across North America and nobody has
figured out how to use it
it's like the force
sorry have you seen Star Wars no
that guy is sketchy I don't think it's
sketchy the guy's a shark I know how to
Market it and I know who we can sell it
to but I want 50 of the company and I've
got to be CEO I don't know who you think
you are oh deal
are you joking
[Music]
we are in a race to get this thing to
Market and we are a year behind I need a
prototype I'll do it perfectly or I
don't do it Mike are you familiar with
the saying perfect is the enemy of good
well good enough is the enemy of
humanity
what do you call it
it's called a Blackberry hmm try typing
with your thumbs
[Music]
baby in the hands of every Fortune 500
executive you could find they're calling
crack berries
Sean is like sure come with us sir no
you want to be great you need to
sacrifice the more painful the sacrifice
the greater you'll be
if we put more phones on these networks
they're going to crash is this illegal
in blackberries
[Music]
in the middle of the Hostile takeover
do you know what the sentence is for
multi-million dollar stock price what
are you doing
I have no idea I don't
want to create it this entire Market
you said they were the best engineers in
the world I said they're the best
engineers in Canada
what are they paying you I shouldn't say
it they're paying me 10 million dollars
yeah me too
[Music]
foreign